this is a giant praying mantis
it's located here in las vegas nevada
but it's not located on the strip the
place that most people think of when
they think vegas today we're venturing
off the beaten path with the help of
three people hi hi
hi to three places that are
single-handedly keeping vegas weird
this is tim arnold he's the director of
stuff and things at the pinball hall of
fame in las vegas
pinball hall of fame is an old auto
parts store with a bunch of pinball
machines we dug out of dumpsters uh no
no no it's a marvelous museum full of
antique treasures that have been
lovingly restored to their original
condition that we actually let the
public come in and play
we have games from the 30s on up to
today's modern games i've seen people
walking down an aisle full of pinball
machines and they'll stop dead ah
i i the first time i kissed a girl was i
was playing that game and i can't
believe it's here again
this is not something that can be
digitized and sent down the pipes on the
internet
this is something that only exists in
the real world and the only place to
play it
is here okay tim we're sold who's got
change for a dollar my name's christine
reynolds she's the general manager at
downtown container park which is
completely made of shipping containers
we wanted to reuse materials instead of
just building from scratch container
park prides itself on helping out mom
and pop type of brands there are unusual
shops like kappa toys which specializes
in throwback toys and there's
exceptional grub to be had too
and let's not forget about the mantis
and this guy who makes her move
our last stop in downtown las vegas is a
totally novel literary adventure i am
drew cohen my husband and i own the
writer's block together so you could say
we're a pop and pop establishment we
have a lot of kooky installations and
objects in the store we have an antique
letter press from 1890 we have a machine
called bear show who will produce a
haiku on demand for 25 cents we have a
mailbox that belongs to the king pigeon
and you can leave a question in an
envelope and return in one week for your
answer and it all goes to support free
writing classes for local students
so there you have it three delightfully
strange places you can only find off the
beaten path in vegas
this city is a very eccentric one you
can encounter a lot of really wacko and
awesome businesses if you are willing to
venture out a little bit
if you want to do shopping there's
shopping
the nightlife here is amazing it's
really is
something you can't see
in your hometown and that's the
definition of why you come to vegas it
has dancing fountains and pinball
museums and all sorts of goofy stuff
so next time you're in vegas try strain
from the strip
[Music]